[Music]
my name is Rob Sadowski I work in the
product organization on security and
Trust here at Google cloud we'll also
have Eugene Lederman he's gonna speak
later about devices and I'll let him do
his own introduction and publicity okay
so what are we gonna cover today here's
our agenda to do this topic justice I
think first we need to describe what we
mean by modern end-user computing what's
modern who are the users this baseline
understanding is really going to help us
understand and think through what it
takes to provide robust enterprise
curity in that environment we're going
to need to think about applications
we're going to need to think about users
we're going to need to think about
devices and securing each of these
presents a unique set of challenges
but solving the overall challenge of
modern end-user computing and how we
make sure that that's secure and
productive is going to require us to
follow some you know basic good security
principles we're going to take a
defense-in-depth approach we're gonna
have a solution that encompasses
protection at multiple layers in every
layer in a much much more holistic way
so let's get in and start with some
context about the modern end-user
computing environment because it's the
thing that's creating the security
challenges and the opportunities that
we're all facing today
so everyone hold up your phones I know
you were told to silence your phones yes
everyone has a phone and how many of you
are taking notes are doing something
else on a laptop some people right so
this is today's reality this is what
we're talking about in terms of modern
air using computing we work wherever we
are even if we're in a movie theater
right at a conference in San Francisco
how is this possible well one the access
device is supported right we have
always-on connectivity we have really
much more convenient form factors than
lugging around a desktop or something
like that we have a decreasing
dependence on fat client apps that have
to work across multiple operating
systems and things like that and
means that you and your employees and
the people that you work with the users
on these devices can access your work
apps not just the consumer side apps
that your kind of consumer izing and
using potentially for work stuff but you
can actually access the primary tools
and apps you use to get your job done
through a browser or a much more
lightweight mobile client second what we
are accessing is increasingly not
sitting in one of our own data centers
and that traditionally has created a lot
of challenges around connectivity in
doing that at scale so much more of what
we are accessing to get our our primary
work done is in the cloud and therefore
it's on a public network and you know
these networks of something to which we
have pretty ubiquitous access you came
to this conference and just assumed that
you'd have a pretty solid high bandwidth
connection now that's mostly worked if
you were here last year didn't work so
well but this years so far so good right
so we all we all assumed that we were
going to be able to do that and that's
great but failing that guess what we've
a backup we have wireless connectivity
on our phones right so we are always
connected and that creates a lot of
opportunities but potentially some
challenges so the technology is there
but why else have we embraced mobility
so strongly because what we find is that
when we do it leads to increase
productivity increase collaboration and
reduced overhead so you know some of the
data here is actually really really
compelling there's been a two-year
Stanford study two years right so it's
not just hey do a quick survey that
showed a 13% increase in productivity
when users work from home you know again
that's that modern end-user model other
research indicates that employee
mobility leads to 30% better business
processes better following a processes
better you know redesigning things to
work better and 23% more productivity
these are real significant gains and
that we you know find and I think this
is our own experience that working from
home reduces attrition right so
retaining and keeping talent is so
important in today's world anything we
can do and something with the lever like
that
so important the other thing is that
these devices and this way of working
allows us to communicate and work
asynchronously so kind of asynchronous
communications that facility that are
facilitated by devices and cloud
technology allow us to be more efficient
web-based meetings are better planned
and more apt to stay on message I can't
remember the last time I didn't have a
web-based meeting or do you know do
things on conference calls but more and
more and more we're getting more done in
less time the net-net is that modern
communication and collaboration can
increase productivity again you know 25
30 plus percent and increase employee
satisfaction and yes you know usually
when we talk about benefits we go right
to costs and certainly there's a there's
an element of cost savings here
something like that you know you look at
what IBM does that they've been really
public about how they have moved to
essentially a remote workforce folks
that work and are enabled by these
technologies and they've saved more than
50 million dollars by making many of
their positions remote so while cost
savings probably isn't a primary benefit
in a lot of cases it is certainly part
of the equation but this new model of
working means we are also faced with a
new set of risks right security
professionals when you say ok what's
going on now
what are you concerned about they find a
lot of challenges in defending against
threats to mobile devices and this
survey you know ranks them the number
one hardest enterprise asset to defend
right there's a lot of user intervention
there's a lot of user control there
right that's a pretty strong statement
the number one or most difficult asset
to defend and three-quarters of
organizations report that they've
suffered some sort of breach or incident
as a result of a mobile security issue
so these aren't likely to be the big
mega breaches where you know you aren't
storing you know hundreds of millions of
records on a mobile device but
nevertheless you know when we have
regulations like gdpr where we have to
you know disclose when you know personal
information is disclosed that type of
information does get on to devices and
so this is an increasing increasing
concern even if it isn't the large mega
catastrophic breach that it may be it's
all still very very important
so how do we enable the business how do
we unleash that productivity without
increasing or creating unnecessary
security risk well to do that we need a
strategy that thinks through and
understands the whole stack that we are
using to deliver IT services in this new
world and as I said before we have to
take a defense-in-depth approach it's
not just just about the device although
that's really important it starts at the
infrastructure we have to think about
the apps that are on these devices and
the apps that we are delivering
information through to these you know to
these workers we have to think about the
users and how we establish their
identity we have to think again about
the devices so we need to build
protection into every layer and take
advantage of the controls that are there
so we can build end-to-end security so
what I'd like to do now is kind of walk
through what we can do each in each
layer and what specifically you can get
from Google cloud what we're doing in
many of these in each so perhaps now but
certainly going forward the services
that workers access to do their jobs
will be largely based in the cloud right
and while this used to be seen as a
source of risk it's now seen cloud
infrastructure is now seen as a security
enabler or a strength you know Gartner
says that over the next several years
workloads that leverage cloud
infrastructure right whatever those
workloads are will suffer 60% fewer
incidents than those in traditional data
centers that has a really really strong
compelling statement and I think that
you know the experience that people have
in operating the cloud bears this out
you know another study that I cited in
another talk this week is that going
from last year to this year of
organizations that are that are putting
applications in the cloud 90 plus
percent of them trust the cloud more
right it's that repeated positive
experience that they are getting that
they are realizing that the cloud is
actually cloud infrastructure is not
part of the security problem it's part
of the solution right so how do we
leverage that in this modern world to
increase security
so the foundational layer of our stack
right that's what I want you to take
away the infrastructure is getting more
secure over
in a Google cloud the infrastructure
layer that we provide offers many unique
benefits that you can take advantage of
so we do a lot of security by default
right when data is stored or services
that run in our cloud when you put data
in there all of that data is encrypted
at rest by default without any potential
without any interaction required by you
on behalf of the customer or you as a
customer the second thing that we do or
second thing I want to highlight is that
the worst thing that can happen is that
you know someone is working remotely or
working in the field and they can't get
to the application you know the size and
scope of our network as well as the
protections we've built in by default
help organizations mitigate potential
network and DDoS attacks really really
well the other thing is that as you're
deploying apps for those users to to
work on again downtime really really
impacts them we do all the
infrastructure patching automatically so
not only do you get the benefits of a
constantly updated infrastructure that
it's not subjective ulnar abilities but
we don't have to take downtime and this
was a particular you know particularly
great feature when the processor
vulnerabilities are a specter and
meltdown that Google researchers
actually found needed to be fixed so
across our whole fleet we were able to
patch that in Google cloud without
taking any downtime which is not the
case on many other services the second
thing is that we are building on our you
building on a purpose-built
infrastructure so we design all the way
from the chip up to the chiller in the
datacenter our own our own
infrastructure that's the chips that go
on the servers the servers themselves
the storage the networking gear all of
that we have a private global network
and so when we are accessing services on
that traffic that that gets off the
public internet and gets on that network
is much less likely to be intercepted or
manipulated and again I talked a little
bit about the chip side of things we
have hardware based tamper protection
and make sure that the infrastructure
that your app services and data sits on
is always in a state that we know that
we know exactly what is running
there at all times and then we'll get
into this a little bit later on there's
a lot of proprietary controls and
expertise that are embedded here that
you can take advantage of so we'll talk
a little bit about you know the way that
this is in G suite like Gmail do things
like fishing and protection against
malicious email we talked about the easy
way you can implement strong
authentication with security keys and
some of the things we do there we talk
about the ways we can prevent data
exfiltration from certain services with
things like PPC service controls and
just this week we introduced a set of
what we call user protection services
that help deal with risk of suspicious
or malicious URLs and applications that
look at again other ways to do phishing
defense and protect applications against
abuse by bots or other things like that
and the other thing that we do from a
security perspective that is really
important as the operator administrator
of the infrastructure like this is we
provide a tremendous amount of
visibility and transparency so you her
may be heard or is in the in the keynote
today talk about access transparency
where you can understand if any cloud
administrators are ever accessing your
data in the course of doing support and
things like that so you can feel
confident that what you are doing is
robust we also give a lot of visibility
into just overall operations you know
with our Cloud Security Command Center
on GCP and our Security Center within G
suite to really highlight where are the
particular areas of security risk so
what what I want to you know again to
take away is that there's a really
robust foundation for building the apps
and delivering the services that these
modern end users these mobile users need
the other thing is that I'll building on
an infrastructure like this you get the
assurance that not only the
infrastructure but the services that sit
on top are validated against some of the
most rigorous global security and
privacy standards like the ISO 27000
series and we know that as you adopt
this infrastructure foundation you may
want to bring some of your existing
security tools with you so we've
extensive ecosystem of security partners
that deliver their capabilities on cloud
platforms and you know on our cloud
platform that runs the gamut from things
like Identity and Access Management
solutions
monitoring solutions GRC solutions
endpoint security which which I'll talk
about in a few slides here cloud access
security brokers which are really
important for some organizations in
getting the level of control that they
want in this perilous world so you can
preserve existing investment things like
your endpoint protection platforms and
still leverage those as you build on our
cloud infrastructure so hopefully you
take away why clouded that foundation in
many ways does or will underpin what
we're doing around modern end-user
computing so now let's turn our
attention to some of the layers of the
stack we more commonly associate with
these challenges about the apps about
the users and about the devices so the
layer above the infrastructure is the
application layer and these can be
applications that you build or deploy in
the cloud yourself or they can be SAS or
other services from a third party but
regardless we need to think about what
are the features and what are
capabilities that we're looking for so
in terms of what we can offer and the
way we think about some of this within
Google Cloud G suite offers many
security benefits that are really
attuned to the needs of this modern
workforce a much more collaborative and
things like that first G suite is very
you know one of the we've these core
guiding principles around being
proactive about being intelligent making
things simple and building compliance in
so you know in terms of being proactive
what we are looking to do is
automatically block many of the threats
that target cloud workers especially in
email I think we're all aware the email
is the number one app you know the most
critical app for these mobile more
modern workers and G suite has 99.9%
plus accuracy in blocking spam in
blocking malicious email in dealing with
business email compromised type scams
all the outbound email is checked
automatically if you turn on things like
DLP for sensitive information and so
that can be automatically flagged again
potentially eliminate
sources of risk or data exposure and
there are built-in defenses as email
comes in against attachments carrying
ransomware another malware that can get
on a they can get on the device that
users are using an effective security
there right so in today we announces
some new advances in G suite in this
area around stronger phishing and
malware protection and some sandboxing
technology that goes even further in
allowing us to deal with more
sophisticated malware so we constantly
keep pushing and in trying to advance
the state-of-the-art the other thing
that we think about is again this notion
of intelligence and being proactive we
want to help stop threats to this work
force to these devices before they turn
into damaging incidents and the
intelligence that's in G suite can help
surface the most worrisome security
concerns like potential device
compromises we have a part of our G
suite security Center has a whole
specific section that allows you to look
at your device footprint and understand
is there a potential compromise there
which users is it affecting so you can
deal with this and we try to do this
without sending you constant
notifications about less important
issues that are less impactful and again
we strive to make these simple we have
this you know philosophy that security
tools are only useful if you actually
use them if you actually deploy them and
so if they're too difficult or too
complicated
they're of limited use we're always
trying to give admin simpler more
streamlined ways to deploy this make a
lot of the things available again by
default like I talked about and make
them work out of the box with the right
with the right configurations right at
your fingertips
so now when I mention an application
security layer how many people actually
thought about browsers maybe some of you
but perhaps not many of you the fact is
many if not the majority of corporate
apps are or will be delivered in
browsers even up to productivity things
like think of what we do with G suite
think of the sophistication we get in
Docs and sheets and other things like
that or you know some of the other
productivity Suites it's an essential
the browser
is an essential part of that application
layer that we need to have confidence in
the security of and Chrome browser for
enterprise designs in many security
features right we think of that in three
broad areas we try to make it safe as
much as possible by design so to build
those protections in here again just
like we're describing a multi-layered
approach chrome takes that same
multi-layered approach in the browser
itself and we try to do many many things
to keep ahead of the threat landscape
that targets the end-user environment so
in terms of being safe by design we
employ technologies like Safe Browsing
which protects from a range of malware
phishing and social engineering attacks
the sites that might be able to steal
passwords or infect machines that would
affect those users this is a constantly
updated database as we crawl the web of
what we perceive or what we see as
potentially malicious sites and we'll
provide warnings to users before they
navigate to those so again it gets that
distributed notion of warning or control
out to users wherever they may be
chrome automatically updates right this
is so important for this modern mobile
workforce you know if you're not in the
office if you're not doing updates if IT
staff and team and desktop support staff
is not touching that on a regular basis
where they can do updates we have to
constantly update you know the OS the
application software and all those other
pieces because we know that
vulnerabilities get exploited very
rapidly the fact that cloud-based
services automatically update and grow
Chrome browser especially automatically
you know updates is really particularly
important to make sure that the users
have the latest security features and
fixes without requiring any intervention
right sandboxing is another thing in
terms of design that is very you know
very very useful in terms of the chrome
security model it helps prevent malware
from installing itself on devices
reduces the severity and impact of
certain vulnerabilities that might be
exploited it also works again to prevent
eavesdropping or other intercept of
communications as the browser access
website so it uses network security
features like secure strict Transport
Security things like public key pinning
things like verification of route CAS to
make sure so building on what we do at
Google around certificate transparency
in doing things like mixed script
locking so there's a lot of things or a
lot of potential ways that a browser can
be exploited but the design of Chrome
tries to neutralize or make many of
those much less or make itself much less
susceptible to those type of techniques
and chrome really works to stay ahead of
threats you know there's a public
commitment to releasing a fix for any
critical security vulnerability in under
60 days and on average those
vulnerabilities are fixed within 30 days
and even when necessary you know we
think the things something is
particularly severe with push fixes in
under 24 hours so the team is really
always actively working to find and fix
vulnerabilities before they affect users
and that's you know that point about
trying to stay and working to stay one
step ahead of potential adversaries so
that's the app lair but what about users
how should we think about protecting
this broad and increasingly growing user
community and I think that's the first
point
I want to make the notion of who is a
user in this more modern world is
evolving it's not just employees it goes
beyond that its vendors its partners its
contractors its customers and all of
those different user constituencies
require different levels of access to
different information to different data
sources to different applications from
different places on different devices
right think of that matrix it's
complicated
how can we help deal with some of those
challenges so back in 2011 Google came
up with a new approach for access
management you know dealing with these
types of challenges we called it beyond
Corp in this enterprise security model
started off as an internal Google
initiative to say that hey we want to
enable any of our employees to work and
we're essentially in the world from
untrusted networks right we want to rely
on the Internet not have to rely on a
VPN which can be very complex this
actually sounds really close to this
description of modern end-user computing
that I talked about at the beginning so
what beyond Corp aims to do is shift the
access controls being solely based at
the network layer and around the
perimeter to switch that much much more
into or make it much much more about
context about the user about the device
and what they're accessing in Arbit
decisions based on that right don't just
make an assumption about trusting the
network because we know that these
modern end-users are not going to be
working from inside the office where we
have that presumption of trust and
because of the trends that we've been
speaking about there's been tremendous
support for an idea like this if any of
you were at kind of the RSA security
conference over the past month I think
the biggest theme that came out for me
was this idea around how do we implement
zero trust networking how do we take
models like beyond Corp and actually
make them real because conceptually they
address a lot of the challenges that
we've been talking about here's a great
quote from Steve hue he's at a company
called ionic now who's a Google partner
but he used to be the in the office of
the CTO and various el bridges of the
military and in the White House and he
says this is this vision is really the
future of enterprise IT right this is
the modern world that we are that we are
dealing with it's a model that builds on
on zero trust and combined with Best of
Breed ideas from the community so we've
tried to adapt and see what's you know
the challenges and in terms of
implementation and adjust and go on and
so at Google cloud we've been working
really hard over the past year or so to
help you implement a similar type model
implement this beyond Corp model for
users through a set of products and
capabilities on our on our platform and
our services and we put this under the
umbrella of what we call context-aware
access we want to enable you to make
context aware access decisions
for any type of user to any type of
resource within cloud and what we do
here is we take inputs from the user
side and we take input from the device
side and then we incorporate a whole
range of contextual factors like IP
address like location like the time of
day like the length of the session we
run those through a rules engine right
do we call access context manager and we
leverage a number of enforcement points
so that we can control access for remote
users to the diverse set of resources
that they're looking to get access to so
whether those are web apps whether those
are virtual machines whether those are
other services or resources on GCP
whether those are api's whether that's g
suite whether that's generic SAS apps
right any of those we want to be able to
set precise access policies and rules
that take into account the environment
that users are finding themselves in and
a key enabler for this that Google a
Google cloud is providing is our cloud
identity solution so it's our repository
for user information that we have to
understand it's our identity as a
service solution our ID s solution that
offer the one single place to manage
users apps and devices it allows you to
get this context to our access
capability for G suite and SAS
it allows you you know in to help with
the account hijacking side of things to
implement strong two-factor
authentication with security keys and
other methods to prevent account
takeovers it does a lot of account
protection in the background based on
Google's intelligence and signals and
what we do to protect the billions of
accounts that access our services it
offers this is really important
integrated unified endpoint management
both from a lightweight perspective and
also more in-depth if you want to do
that so to get that to get that touch it
offers a dashboard that I made a little
bit of mention of in terms of
highlighting where the biggest sources
of risk and what's going on across these
different identities and this is a
service that is now today
used by customers to manage more than a
hundred million users and over 55
million devices so you know this is one
of the kind of almost best-kept secrets
with inside Google Cloud and really is a
fundamental underpinning of how we are
enabling and how we are helping people
to work in this new modern environment
so what I wanted to do is kind of stop
talking and let and do a little bit of a
demo to show you how this actually might
work to show you how these different
layers from the infrastructure layer to
the a player to the user protection
layer how all these can work in concert
and how implementing context to are
access for your modern end users
actually looks like so here's a business
scenario that poses a lot of the
challenges that we face dealing with
this modern end-user computing
environment so we have a company called
za Kicks they work with a company called
Acme so already we see kind of the
complexity in the collaborative nature
of work and so in this scenario the suc
--tx our department is going to hire or
bring on some contractors from Acme to
help with a few things so they are going
to need access to the internal HR system
well there are no you know notion of an
internal system we want to make that
available as a service you know so that
user can access it theoretically from
wherever they are but the security
policies that they have in place require
some very specific things for
contractors to access them they should
use strong authentication in every case
and in this particular case for HR we
actually aren't going to allow you to
work from anywhere you must be on or
accessing this from a company office and
so the IT department while this may have
been a daunting challenge in the past
it's absolutely the type of thing we
have to do in today's in today's world
in today's environment so their IT
department says consider it done to both
HR and security so how are they going to
do this well they're going to deploy
this HR application on Google cloud
they're going to define a VP see virtual
private cloud network for the rapp and
they're going to stand it up on Google
compute engine and then they are going
to set up cloud load balancing right at
the edge for ingress from the internet
and they're going to use the cloud
identity aware proxy which is integrated
right into cloud load balancing -
front-end the app okay so those are all
the features that they have the taking
advantage of what they're and I the
identity where proxy IP is going to draw
in user information that they maintain
and cloud identity it's going to rely on
device status from endpoint verification
and Chrome browser and the access
context manager is going to be used to
define their access policy so this is
why I talked about the cloud
infrastructure layer first in talking
about modern end-user computing these
key enabling services that we need to
enable you know us to work the way we
want our part of the infrastructure
where the app and the data and the
mobile users that they're going to
access where all this lives so let's
take a look at what this looks like
the first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna set up the access policy that
restricts access to the office for this
app for contractors and because I fear
the demo gods a little bit in a movie
theater and I respect your time I
actually recorded this earlier so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go what I did
is they go to the GCP console and I'm
gonna go to security and go to access
context manager so really easy to do
right here in the console and you can
see as we select this you can see I have
a whole set of existing policies here
but I want to go and define a new access
level and I'm gonna call this from Acme
office make it very descriptive so type
that in don't always type that fast and
then I'm going to add an attribute and
here what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
specify an IT based attribute and I'm
gonna specify the IP range that
corresponds to the internal office now
when I go ahead and save that really
really quickly that is going to show up
in my list over here it says that my
level is created and down here I can see
that new policies in my list of access
context manager policies alright so far
so good
so next I'm gonna go in and I'm gonna
configure the identity aware proxy so
I'm gonna go in I'm gonna pick my
project I'm gonna click on the service
the backend service that connects to the
HR app and then I'm gonna go in I'm
gonna add members which allows me to say
what group of users that this policy is
going to apply to you remember we're
identity aware right
that's the key point of this and so I'm
gonna add in the group name which
includes all the contractors I'm gonna
select the policy that we just defined
there it is
scroll down from the acne office and I'm
gonna save all of this it's going to
instantiate it's gonna get loaded along
with the other policies that you see
there on the right and so that's the
admin experience it's really
straightforward right so this is you
know might have seemed wow this is
really complex but it's actually fairly
simple to step through all right now
let's flip it over and take a look at
the user experience so we're in a
browser because it's a modern app for an
end user for a modern end user and look
I'm on the Wi-Fi inside of Acme Corp so
we're gonna hit the URL for the HR app
our user is going to be asked to sign in
okay we do that we put in our password
and now because we have that policy
we're gonna be asked to authenticate
with a security key again according to
our policy and since we've satisfied all
the requirements we're in the office
we're authenticated we're authenticated
with the security key we can get in and
get access to that app so let's change
things up a little bit further and see
what happens when we don't meet the
conditions so now we're working remotely
you can see that we go on and we're
actually on Starbucks public Wi-Fi out
there on Third Street and so we're gonna
go in and rel for the HR app just like
we did before
hopefully my mic does not die while I go
through this I only have to talk for
another minute or two here so we're
hoping and we're asked to sign in with
the security key but what happens now
the login fails because we didn't meet
all the requirements in the policy so
here you know look we have multiple
layers we have the infrastructure we
have the app we have the user we have
protection that's working in every level
working in concert to provide the
security and ease of use for the modern
end-user and the way they work and one
last thing you know we didn't talk too
much about devices although that's one
way you can define policies and device
trust is a really really key input for
this context to where access model we
know that we can get device context from
Chrome browser via an extension but we
know many organizations already have
mobile management
solutions in place that they're using to
secure this mobile workforce so today we
announce something we called our beyond
Corp alliance and what it is is a
partnership with a number of the key
endpoint and mobile security vendors who
can help provide device status data back
into Google cloud from their products so
you can use the data that's coming from
these platforms to make better access
decisions on whether or not that product
says the device is in a safe state or
not so it's great validation I think for
our vision and approach of what we're
doing here from other leaders in the
end-user computing security space and
that's really a great segue about into
devices and so the final layer we want
to talk about is the device and there's
a bunch here we want to go through so
I'm gonna turn that over to Eugene
really quickly diving in it's so hard to
see everybody the light is shining so
bright it's like nobody's actually here
so when it comes to device is taking a
step back about devices for a second
obviously you know Google has Chrome OS
and Android OS and we work with a
variety of ecosystem partners device
manufacturers you know obviously we have
our own devices but there's a huge broad
ecosystem of partners out there and one
of the things that's really important
when it comes to both Android OS and
Chrome OS is Google's commitment to
transparency and openness right I think
Rob touched on a little bit earlier you
know obviously Android is open source
Chrome OS is built on chromium which is
open source anybody can go see the
contributions that we make the changes
that we make we blog about new features
as they come out we publish in depth
white papers and reviews we actually
just published an Android security and
privacy your interview a couple weeks
back and we also publish transparency
reports to highlight the state of the
ecosystem so we have an Android
ecosystem transparency report we also
have chrome Safe Browsing transparency
report so you know it's just part of our
ethos we try to be transparent with
everything we do when it comes to these
mobile operating systems so speaking of
security I think Rob touched on this
before
obviously you're hearing a lot it's it's
all about secure by design security is a
foundational principle we we have
dedicated security teams right for both
Chrome OS and Android OS we're
continually improving security always
adding additional hardware based
security features
anta exploitation techniques you know
and just implementing it at every layer
you've probably heard you said
defense-in-depth
layered security the onion model
whatever analogy you want to use we're
constantly beefing up our security for
these operating systems and so just to
highlight some of the at a high level
the pillars or not pillars but the stack
you know obviously it's like I mentioned
Hardware based security you got we
obviously used the Linux kernel so we
implements a lot of security around
sandbox and app security security for
the data on the devices and one of the
things that's interesting about having a
broad ecosystem of partners is obviously
you know coming up with design
principles and requirements and then
having to make and making sure that
these partners are actually implementing
everything's done so far on the Android
side we have the compatibility
definition document the States what must
be implemented by our partners and then
they go through various conformance
tests are like CTS VTS STS to make sure
that they conform and these devices ship
to our standards so starting with
Hardware back security I think Rob
mentioned a little bit on the GCP side
of course we want to make sure that when
the device boots up it boots into a
verified state so we have verified boot
verified boot for anybody that does know
it basically verifies the boot up
process cryptographically at every stage
so if something bad happens during the
boot process it will alert the user and
react from there so some some examples
for verified boot and why it's necessary
of course obviously malware is a
universal risk and the first thing mal
what we're trying to do is modify the
system partition and persist and so with
verified boot when the device boots up
if something bad happens it catches it
notifies the user and since these
operating systems are modern they
actually have two copies of the OS so
what it will do is if the primary copy
is in a known bad state it will try to
roll back to the other copy if it's the
same version right so in terms of
additional platform security features
that are hardware based so of course
both OSS have full-on device encryption
they actually follow based encryption so
full data at rest
they both leverage the hardware based
security for key generation and key
storage they both of course benefit from
the using the Linux kernel and so
they're both
implemented with mandatory access
control where everything is broken down
in specific sub components kind of
protecting one from another making sure
that something does bad happens and it
doesn't go across the entire OS and then
of course as Rob touched earlier with
sandboxing the same thing happens that
on the device OS is of course we
implement application sandbox and for
both alessa's where every single app is
isolated it has its own resources such
as processing memory and storage and one
cannot go and eavesdrop on one another
right and the last thing is you will see
over the last couple years
both alessa's have heavily added
additional anti exploitation techniques
and methods so address space layout
randomization and in both the user space
in the kernel data execution prevention
control flow integrity you know the the
whole mission there is that the more of
these techniques we can apply you know
obviously these are large OS is hundreds
of thousands millions of lines of code
so if we can implement additional
methodologies like this we basically can
help prevent a potential bug or
vulnerability from becoming exploitable
and compromising the entire operating
system so the next big thing in it you
know I think Rob touch that a little bit
on how easy it is to update on the cloud
side on the mobile device side patching
has also improved iris everybody knows
patched Tuesdays and all those good
examples on Chrome OS and Android OS you
know we provide a nice cadence for
patches for Chrome OS security patches
come out every three weeks two to three
weeks for Android we provide monthly
security both and so the ecosystem and
the the real benefit there is that we've
decoupled security patches or security
updates from feature updates so they're
smaller easier to take and it's also you
know the goal is to make sure that users
have an easy way of adopting these
updates and so both OS has leverage
seamless updates and what that means is
since both OSS have two copies of the OS
on the device what happens is when the
user is idle on the device that device
is just idle and not being used the
updates download in the background and
when it's ready to install it notifies
the user so all the user has to do is
hit restart and all of a sudden you know
the device reboots and you're now
running the latest update and behind the
scenes what really happens is as the OS
reboots in
switches to that secondary copy it
verifies it and if something bad happens
the nice thing is it reverts back to the
last known good copy so there's no risk
of losing data or information on the
Android side obviously since your device
you walk around with your device it's
not always plugged into power and you're
using it we're a little bit more gentle
in the way we do these updates so we
obviously wait until the device is
plugged in you're on Wi-Fi and it's
sitting there idle so it doesn't impact
your usage of the device of course
everybody here's probably familiar with
with the Google Play Store Google Play
Store is what all Android devices all
GMs devices have for access to apps
that's our central app repository
there's obviously millions of apps in
the Play Store what a lot of people
don't know is that Chrome OS also
supports Android apps and it also has
the Play Store and so for an IT
enterprise deployment you can actually
deploy these apps through what we call
manage Google Play this is where you can
allow IT to provide a curated experience
for your applications so you can decide
what applications you want to deploy
they have that nice view of just those
approved applications you can push them
automatically down to the device you can
control update policies you can actually
leverage manage app configurations where
you know if an app developer supports
various configurations obviously every
environment is different this allows
them to customize certain things and
make as changes as they see fit
and what's really neat especially on the
Android side is that since we do support
and that multiple management models with
fully managed and and BYOD with a work
profile you can actually end up having a
personal instance of play where the user
can do what you know download whatever
the apps they choose and then in the
work profile which is basically a
separate Linux user on the device
although it's in the same user
experience you end up having a separate
manage Google Play that IT can curate
and there's that perfect separation so
that you know I t's not overreaching on
to the personal side for the user and
their device so obviously I think I
touched earlier malware is a universal
risk right and so Rob touched on Chrome
Safe Browsing which is widely used
across Chrome OS and Android the other
thing that we have is Google Play
protect which is our built-in
anti-malware solution it's actually the
largest or most widely used anti-malware
solution out there
it basically scans over 50 50 billion
apps across 2 billion devices every
single day on the backend that also
analyzes and reanalyze about 500,000
apps every single day it leverages
machine learning artificial intelligence
static analysis dynamic analysis
heuristics heat maps and many other
techniques and it works for both off
play and on play as well as offline so
even if the device is not connected it's
still scanning and remediating and if it
finds a potentially harmful application
which is what we on the android security
and privacy privacy side refer analogous
to malware it can remediate that and
remove it off the device or notify the
user and so forth in terms of like I had
mentioned earlier we talked about
transparency and openness we publish an
annual Year in Review which we just
published two weeks ago and this year
the likelihood of you have a higher
likelihood of dying in a bathtub than
you do of installing a potentially
harmful application from the Play Store
I know very more but nobody likes that
stat for some reason but I still went
with it so this is something new that we
just added we just announced this today
so again Rob touched on hardware
security keys of course G suite supports
this a lot of third-party solutions as
well support this and as of today you
can actually use your Android phone as a
security key so it's basically Android
nougat at above and so that's a billion
plus devices that have the ability to
now leverage this functionality on all
of those devices it actually does use
hardware based security because it's
using the trusted execution environment
to store those keys and then
specifically on pixel three devices that
have the Titan M chip it actually
leverages that discreet tamper resistant
hardware with the strong box API and
these of course work over Bluetooth with
your existing laptops and desktops so
one of the other things that you know
kind of the key things that we focus on
is measurable security
you know we'd like to set benchmarks
we'd like to see how we do and so this
is actually something the Gartner
publishes every year this they have a
new report actually coming out very soon
so this is the previous report but this
is the mobile OS comparison report it's
pretty comprehensive but there's about
twenty eight categories and it focuses
on platform security features like
network security Oh
updates app updates and then specific
Enterprise requirements around policy
management authentication controls key
management and so forth and what you'll
see highlighted there in the orange box
the the ones that scored the highest in
this report were all Android devices so
Android or EO the pixel 2 on Android or
EO and a Samsung device an Android Oreo
in fact the pixel 2 received a high
rating in 24 out of 28 categories and
comparatively if you look at some of the
other LSE's they scored half of that so
to close google cloud with GCP g sweet
chrome and Android help you secure
securely enabled this is the last slide
that I'd never could get right security
label modern and these are computing
with security capabilities from the
device that the data center we can help
keep your enterprises secure and you and
your users productive thank you
[Music]